over institution senior fellow Victor
Davis Hansen joins me now with former
White House Press Secretary Fox News
contributor Ari fer AR ah what about
this I mean again Biden's attack on
Trump uh surrogates attack on Trump
because he didn't say much during the
campaign was that things had gotten
chaotic the world was a more dangerous
place under Donald Trump how's that
working out boy was the world a safer
place under Donald Trump look you know
what we have to recognize As Americans
and around the world is we're dealing
with the heirs to the attack of
September 11th there is no difference
between Hamas and Al-Qaeda we're dealing
with the heirs to Isis The Butchers who
behead people burn people alive this is
what we're dealing with with Hamas this
is why they attacked Israel there is no
justice in anything that Hamas does or
stands for or seeks they want the
destruction of the only Democratic state
in the region the only Jewish State on
the globe they want it destroyed
and that's the ideology we're dealing
with and there's only one way to deal
with it and that's through Force the
United States has to be strong which
we're not the United States helped make
this happen by giving Iran the money we
gave Iran by giving Iran the sanctions
relief we gave Iran and that is Joe
Biden who did that Donald Trump didn't
do that a tweet by Donald Trump didn't
do that Joe Biden did it by Design and
now Joe Biden needs to block that six
billion he needs to unfreeze it or
refreeze it he let it go they didn't
send it they said why would they send it
now Victor Davis Hansen I I want to play
something that aired on CNN yesterday
now this was uh on a show hosted by
fared Zakaria who's a well-known uh
globalist uh with Mustafa barudi is a
leader of the Palestinian um National
initiative watch
this they're not fighting the Israeli
government they're fighting Ordinary
People that's one way of putting it but
it's not true
I think Hamas mainly attacked military
establishments military installations
and most of the people they they have
arrested and taken as pres war war
prisoners are military people I do not
accept attacking any
civilian now Victor this is the same CNN
that essentially thinks we should
deplatform Donald Trump during the
presidential election he shouldn't be
allowed to speak and you shouldn't cover
his rallies because he's too dangerous
misinformation information yet that
individual oh no they're not attacking
military no nothing but military people
burning children
alive yeah well everything that comes
out of the West Bank and Gaza is a lie
they're mendacious and CNN knows that
and yet they're so wetted to this
leftwing narrative and their viewers and
the base of the democratic party is
joined at the hip with this leftwing Pro
homas movement they can't do anything
people warned when Biden came came into
office Laura people warned him not to
resume Aid to the Palestinians and in
Gaza and his own State Department warned
him that it would be fungible they
warned him not to give money to Iran
they warned him not to do this Iran
hostage deal they warned him not to uh
drop the sanctions people warned
everybody warned him not to appoint
Robert mauy who's now under
investigation by the FBI he was their
Iran nuclear negotiator they wanted to
get back in the N Iran they said this
guy is not reliable he's an anti-semite
and what he's under investigation for
maybe Espionage but surely dissemination
of classified documents and then we so
this is completely what you'd expect and
Joe Biden is nowhere to be seen every
four or five hours he pops up and says
he stands with Israel and then he
disappears and then he outsources it to
whom Anthony blinkin makes an estatement
with a pro Hamas Turkish foreign
minister and then immediately calls for
for ceasefire after 900 Jews have been
butchered and then he deletes his tweet
and then the something called the US
office of Palestinian Affairs tweets
right at the beginning no no no counter
violence do not react this is the US
government and then they delete their
tweet they can't even get their their
act straight and this goes out all over
the world in other words would they do
that with Ukraine La would they say to
the ukrainians you're in a cycle of
violence do not retaliate to Putin
aggression by violent they would never
do that and yet that's what this
government has been doing and it's
completely discredited unfortunately and
I think a lot of people are terrified uh
of the Israelis now the Hamas talked
really big that they wanted this war
They begged for it all of their
supporters have bragged about it and all
of a sudden Hamas and everybody says
Israelis they can't they can't react
because they know what's coming and this
is the first time in Israeli history
that the gloves are off and there's not
going to be anybody to say with any
credibility you can't do this not after
you butcher in a
pre-valentine change is an existential
threat it could you know it actually
threatens and is capable of wiping out
all human life on Earth uh over time I
mean that's I don't know how more
existential you can get to that the
president believes wholeheartedly that
climate change is an existential threat
to the all human life on the planet
that's just science that's
fact even during war Ari yeah they go to
their point of major fanaticism which is
climate change that's what should
Americans should be uniting around not
Israel's
survival you know for the 200 people who
were killed attending a music festival
attending a music festival is an
existential threat these days because of
terrorism you know we've got to remember
we've been in a lull since September
11th we Americans have grown complacent
so have many people around the world
this is a reminder that radical Islam
still exists and Laura do you think for
a second if they could get into the
United States they wouldn't do this and
butcher Americans innocent americ an and
grandmothers and Children Here on our
streets if they get into this country
they will do the exact same cuz that's
who they are and Victor brought up
something very important about secretary
blank's call with the Turkish foreign
minister in which he urged turkey to
cooperate and support a ceasefire they
tweeted that from the state department
and as Victor said they deleted it well
they need to release the text of that
phone call it's not the Tweet if he
actually said to the Turkish prime
minister yes we support a ceasefire
Lincoln needs to resign how can
America's position be Israel cease fire
after being attacked is should that have
been our position after September 11th
blinkin needs to Res release that phone
call text they have it at the state
department and if he urged a ceasefire
blink's got to go because no one can
trust him well they're all about Trump's
phone calls they wanted all those all
those transcripts panel thank you so
much good to see both of you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else